anders als manch ein anderer politiker
denn dieses irre video von csu politiker
christian schmidt sorgt jetzt für
mächtig aufregung im netz der heute hohe
repräsentant für bosnien und herzegowina
rastet in einer pressekonferenz völlig
aus und bringt die anwesenden
journalisten an
frischfisch
people anders und standing hier im kern
vor dass conti das ist ein traum der
people have lost der life science mehr
notiert just to make politik und gegen
also was sagen er habe ich das ist alles
müll das ist alles möglich sind hier
nicht um irgendwelche politischen
spieler zu stehen das sagt er da in
diesem video und schnauze gesetzt
schönste journalisten an hieß es
er sagt ich entscheide das auch nicht so
ahnung auf am ende bin ich derjenige der
den ton ab angebracht muss ich habe die
schnauze absolut voll also ein
verrücktes video das da im netz kursiert
von christian schmidt
[Musik]